[Música]
bienvenidos a áfrica siete días un
magazine informativo dedicado al
continente africano
comenzamos con los titulares la cop15
terminó el viernes 20 de mayo en costa
de márfil la cumbre se centró en un tema
crucial la desertificación hacemos un
balance de estos 10 días de
conversaciones
arrancó la bienal de arte contemporáneo
de dakar en senegal uno de los eventos
culturales más importantes del
continente nuestra corresponsal nos
presenta una iniciativa para la
democratización de esta celebración que
muchos consideran elitista y les
presentamos un retrato de la estrella de
chiquito que javi lame un joven
inmigrante senegalés que creció en
italia y se hizo famoso en el mundo
gracias a esta red social
en abiyán costa de marfil la cop15
finalizó el pasado 20 de mayo el tema de
la cumbre fue la lucha contra la
desertificación un fenómeno que según la
onu afecta al 40 por ciento de las
tierras del mundo y a la mitad de la
humanidad pedimos a emanuel sec
coordinador de la red de acción por el
clima en áfrica occidental que nos
hiciera un balance de los avances
alcanzados en este encuentro
[Música]
de partición con su quinceava
conferencia de las partes la convención
de las naciones unidas de lucha contra
la desertificación hubo muchos avances y
acuerdos como todos sabemos el problema
de la desertificación y de la sequía ha
afectado a muchos países especialmente
en esos últimos años y se trata de que
todos los países o al menos los más
afectados puedan integrar este problema
en su planificación ya sea a nivel del
desarrollo territorial pero sobre todo a
nivel de estrategia para aumentar el
nivel de resiliencia de las comunidades
para los países desarrollados ya sea a
nivel del desarrollo territorial pero
sobre todo a nivel de estrategias para
aumentar el nivel de resiliencia de las
comunidades
para los países desarrollados se trata
sobre todo de apoyar los esfuerzos que
se realicen en los países más
vulnerables al problema de la sequía y
la desertificación
[Música]
soy bastante optimista sobre todo en
cuanto a la conciencia es decir hemos
conseguido sensibilizar sobre los temas
de la lucha contra la desertificación y
la sequía y la degradación de la tierra
desde gradas
porque no debemos olvidar que son temas
que afectan a los seres humanos miren
las unidades de migración que hemos
vivido traten de preguntar a estas
poblaciones de dónde vienen en su
mayoría te dirán que vienen de
territorios donde ya no hay recursos
donde la tierra está degradada y es ahí
donde tendremos que invertir la
tendencia
julia pero qué negocios aliter son de
grande y que la iba solo a vengarse la
ola tonos entre otras decisiones los
delegados que representaban a más de 190
países se comprometieron a restaurar mil
millones de hectáreas de tierras en día
de desertificación para 2030 y a
reforzar los derechos sobre la tierra
hablamos también con allianz mahamud
coordinadora de programas de la
autoridad intergubernamental para el
desarrollo una agrupación regional de
siete países de áfrica oriental le
preguntamos si cree que las decisiones
adoptadas están a la altura de los
desafíos
[Música]
si los expertos coinciden en que se
trata de un asunto mixto entre los
puntos de recordar están las
conclusiones de la cop15 que volvieron a
poner en la agenda el principio de la
soberanía alimentaria en un contexto
global del conflicto ruso-ucraniano el
segundo punto es la creación de un grupo
de trabajo intergubernamental sobre la
sequía para el período entre 2022 y 2024
con el fin de examinar las posibles
opciones incluidos los instrumentos
políticos globales y los marcos
políticos regionales para apoyar el
cambio de una gestión reactiva a una
gestión proactiva de la sequía
y fenómenos es resident dicen porque es
una realidad a la que los estados deben
adaptarse la sequía y la desertificación
serán más frecuentes e intensas con el
cambio climático este es el caso actual
de áfrica oriental con somalia etiopía y
kenia especialmente afectados por la
escasez de agua y alimentos mientras
hablo según las naciones unidas hay más
de 14 millones de personas que sufren de
inseguridad alimentaria aguda en estos
tres países más de un millón de personas
se han visto obligadas a abandonar sus
hogares por falta de alimentos y ya han
muerto más de tres millones de cabezas
de ganado la situación es la misma en el
sahel donde los niveles de inseguridad
alimentaria son muy preocupantes e
incluso insostenibles en algunas zonas
las conclusiones de la cob son
especialmente silenciosos en cuanto a la
consideración de las comunidades de
locales y los demás temas relacionados
con la desertificación y la sequía esos
problemas se deben también a los
frágiles sistemas de gobernanza y a los
conflictos en el sahel y en el cuerno de
áfrica así como a los problemas de
disponibilidad de tierras la
privatización de grandes áreas para la
industria minera o su uso para proyectos
agrícolas gubernamentales lo que
complica el acceso de la población a los
recursos naturales y aumenta el riesgo
de desplazamiento
accedé población
vamos a cambiar un donde tras un
referendo ciudadano el 20 de mayo de
1972 el país aprobó la constitución de
la república unidad de camerún y se
reconoció así la unificación de los
territorios que habían sido divididos
por la colonización europea
pero hoy 50 años más tarde en la parte
anglófona esta fecha ya no es sinónimo
de celebraciones desde octubre de 2017
el ejército y las fuerzas separatistas
se enfrentan en las dos regiones
anglófonas del noroeste y el suroeste
los orígenes del conflicto se remontan a
la colonización de camerún por francia y
el reino unido- entre 1919 y
1961 las dos regiones anglófonas
estuvieron bajo dominio colonial
británico tras un referéndum organizado
por las naciones unidas en
1961 para que estos dos territorios
eligieran su vinculación a camerún o
nigeria sus habitantes optaron por el
camerún francés pero hoy denuncian su
marginalización por parte del gobierno
central según la organización de
derechos humanos human rights watch el
conflicto ha causado la muerte de 4000
civiles y el desplazamiento forzado de
más de 700.000 personas mientras que
unos 2 millones de personas necesitan
ayuda humanitaria
la bienal de dakar uno de los
acontecimientos de arte contemporáneo
más importantes del continente africano
empezó el pasado jueves 19 de mayo más
de 2500 artistas se dieron cita para
exponer sus obras en la celebración que
durará un mes pero el evento que atrae a
aficionados del arte africano y diversos
actores de este mercado como galeristas
y críticos no llega realmente a la
población para muchos el arte
contemporáneo sigue siendo elitista y
otros ni siquiera conocen el evento para
intentar invertir esta tendencia a la
nueva edición de la bienal propone un
proyecto inédito llevar las obras a la
calle para que todo el mundo pueda
admirar las es un reportaje de nuestra
corresponsal sara sacó desde la capital
senegalesa
es el paseo más famoso de dakar la
comics el se ha convertido en
una galería a cielo abierto
las esculturas gigantes en el espacio
público forman parte por primera vez del
programa oficial de la bienal
estos estudiantes suelen pasearse por
aquí a menudo la iniciativa les encanta
en belén creo que es una buena
iniciativa porque la última vez que pasé
por aquí esta explanada estaba
abandonada ahora podemos disfrutar de
algo interesante aquí es toda una
novedad
es muy bonito la escultura llamó mi
atención desde el otro lado de la calle
el rojo es muy intenso y me interesó
enseguida todas las exposiciones son
gratis durante este mes de bienal
sin embargo serna nunca se había
acercado al arte de esta manera
la gente dice que los museos son caros y
el precio del transporte no ayuda no
tenemos la costumbre de ir a visitar los
museos dale a
2005 visita
para cambiar esta mentalidad
17 artistas han sido invitados a
utilizar el espacio público
guzmán by es un diseñador y conocido por
sus obras en hierro trabajan tea
nacionalmente por primera vez puede
exponer en su barrio
es mi país el malecón el mar mi barrio
enseñar mi trabajo junto con el de otros
artistas en este ambiente y permitir que
la gente pase entre las obras en la
calle y no en una galería es formidable
durante este mes de que respira arte por
todas partes en paralelo a la selección
oficial
450 eventos están previstos fuera de las
salas de exposición con el objetivo de
despertar de interés por el arte de un
público más amplio
les llevamos ahora a conocer a javi la
may un senegalés de 22 años que se ha
convertido en una estrella mundial
gracias a la red social chiquito que el
joven comparte con sus seguidores vídeos
cortos humorísticos que le han
convertido en uno de los influencers más
seguidos del mundo un informe de natalia
mendoza
se ha convertido en un fenómeno mundial
gracias a una idea sencilla reírse de
los vídeos de trucos que se encuentran
en internet como aquí donde esta persona
muestra cómo cortar un limón capilar me
propone una versión mucho más sencilla y
sin pronunciar una palabra
[Música]
la fidh en un par lara vídeo hacer
vídeos silenciosos es mi manera de
hacerme entender en todo el mundo en mis
vídeos no hablo pero utilizó expresiones
faciales gestos nuevos las manos y al
final la gente entiende lo que quiero
decir
cada punto moviendo alemán en los
vídeos que siempre concluye con este
gesto ahora su sello personal
[Música]
lo hago tan a menudo que mis manos están
desgastadas
[Risas]
y funciona en la red social tick tock
kabila me es ahora la segunda cuenta más
seguida del mundo algunos de sus vídeos
han alcanzado más de 200 millones de
vistas
usamos para una foto
es divertido y con un simple gesto puede
entretener a la gente
[Música]
super simple el ph factor que me gusta
que haya empezado en sus vídeos en solo
empezó de la nada y llegó tan lejos
antes de convertirse en una estrella
kabila me vivía de trabajos esporádicos
en las afueras de milán donde creció con
su familia procedente de senegal
es un montón de dato al senegalés pero
no tengo un vínculo muy fuerte con
senegal espero volver algún día allí me
gustaría ir a hacer alguna obra de
caridad quizás ayudar a alguna escuela o
llevar cosas que la gente necesita
ayudar con nada con alguna escuela por
tarea le conoce que margarit mano
ahora las grandes marcas lo codician
para campañas publicitarias en las
calles de milán ya no es raro cruzarse
con su imagen
hablemos ahora de moda en burkina faso
pese a un tenso contexto de seguridad
cada vez son más los jóvenes diseñadores
que se proponen de hacer de la capital
uagadugú una referencia de la moda tras
una pausa de dos años por la pandemia de
kobe 19 la 'fashion week' de uagadugú se
celebró la semana pasada en esta tercera
edición 35 diseñadores se exhibieron sus
colecciones nos despedimos hasta la
semana que viene con imágenes de los
desfiles gracias a los equipos de
producción gracias a nuestro jefe de
edición andrés doncel y gracias a
ustedes por seguirnos
[Música]